[موسيقى]
من قلب القاره السمراء الى ذا جروف ذي
الرياض هكذا يستقبل المطعم الافريقي زواره
على طريقه جنوب افريقيا بالتصاميم
المستوحاه من الطبيعه وبموظفيه الذي جاء
بعضهم من قبيله الزولو كسم المطعم لابراز
الهويه الافريقيه
[موسيقى]
لهم رغم حاجز اللغه في بعض الاحيان لكن في
الغالب الامر ممتع
[موسيقى]
الطعم الافريقي كان مقدما باطباق تعكس
ثقافه الشعب الافريقي لكنه محضر بنكهه
تناسب ذوق زائر العربي والخليجي في موسم
الرياض جبنه بهاراته وجبنا اشياء من
سبايسيز اللي عندهم جبنا اطباق زي عندك في
جنوب افريقيا بس ايش اضفنا عليه ذائقه انه
يستمتع بها
الخليجيه او السعوديه ايوه لقينا الحماس
لقينا الانفعال مع الاجواء
ولاول مره في السعوديه يكون في مطعم جنوب
افريقيا من حيث كان ازياء كاكل كاطباق
ديكورات
وعندما نتحدث عن افريقيا فاول ما قد يخطر
على اذهاننا هي الموسيقى الافريقيه والرقص
المطعم بالحركات السريعه والابتسامات التي
تاثر زوار المطعم وتجعلهم
رهينه السعاده خلال حجمهم فيه
[موسيقى]
من الرياض شهاد المتروك العربيه